hello everyone i'm alana and i was at
san diego comic-con this weekend which
is a great way to miss out on all the
trailers that dropped so i'm catching up
on a bunch that i haven't already
watched i have already seen and did a
reaction to wakanda forever and she-hulk
right now and they're all pretty short
so this shouldn't actually take too long
i'm gonna catch up on shazam
a lot of the rings rings of power
uh house of dragons dungeons and dragons
and then john wick chapter four which
were basically like all the ones that i
feel like i really wanted to catch up on
kind of in order actually so let's start
with shazam fury of the gods official
trailer number one it has
10 million views in three days
wow um
make myself a little bit smaller
let's do it i'm expecting this to be
pretty funny
i don't know let's get into it
i'm an idiot
it's
showtime i don't deserve these powers if
i'm being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman it's so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician nice
very good
come on now let's get down the business
business
i thought it was
like what a weird remix
[Music]
this is very personal binny
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was the signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is gizelle
[Music]
will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
a dragon
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
i actually really like the song um
that's pretty much what i expected i
don't love the like world ending stakes
that dc uh goes for i guess marvel also
goes for but like sometimes i wish it
was just a little bit more contained
which i feel like the first movie did a
really good job of and i am curious what
the interpersonal
conflicts are going to be this time
around with the whole group because we
didn't really see any of that which i
think is actually much more interesting
than god's invading a world it's also a
lot of cg in this trailer which um you
know i guess is just a reality at this
point but i i don't always love it um
i appreciate the humor because i am for
one always entertained by any media
where an adult
is a child uh and has to act as a child
uh that shtick has been around for a
long time and i always find it very
funny i don't know why it tickles me for
some reason
but i thought the first shazam like i
felt like it was way better than i
expected it had a lot of heart seeing a
lot less hot in this trailer but it's in
line with what i thought it would be
um
seems like the comments are pretty
positive too
this is a really good point i love what
dc is doing with the superhero movies
each hero has a different tone and
personality so each movie should reflect
that i agree with that they are all very
very different dc just really lets
things go
off the rails which i actually really
appreciate uh
the reference to the other dc heroes is
an interesting choice especially the
flash because of everything that's going
on with ezra miller i'm very curious to
see how dc handles that i guess that
movie's probably still going to come out
there's a bot foyer
all seem pretty positive
yeah the black atom stuff should be
interesting
um it looks fun and that's all i wanted
from the first one and i feel like i'd
be happy having that in this one as well
uh next up is a lord of the rings the
rings of power standing your comic con
trailer
i'm not very excited about this show as
a huge lord of the rings fan that said i
don't have the hate for it that a lot of
other people do
because i as a person who's been reading
comics since i was a child
learned a very long time ago that i'm
just okay with different forms of
entertainment media not being the same
as the source material or even the
original creators material it's not like
i like it it's not like i'm a fan of
that thing happening there's always
something unsettling about it but i
don't get angry about it anymore um i
kind of learned when i
stopped being a teenager i think that
i'm just like it's okay for things to be
different
i don't need
all the dwarves to have huge beards that
i'm not upset about that it's okay um
but i am a big lord of the rings fan
i'm just not excited about this and i
felt like a lot of
a lot of the actors look just like
weirdly cw
i don't know let's watch the trailer um
i'm i'm coming at it with a much more
open mind than i feel like a lot of the
internet from what i've seen is all i'm
trying to say
we thought the war
at last as you do was ended pile up
helmets of course yes
today
our days of peace
begin
we thought our joys would be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
he looks cute
i said kill because i meant cute and
cool
[Music]
you just heard
the moment we feared
[Music]
evil does not love that shot that's very
pretty
it wins
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to barriers all beneath the mountain
[Music]
that's a nice shot too
that's beautiful
see
it's weird because
sometimes people hate it when i pause in
the middle of the trailer but like if i
get on a thought i'm not gonna be able
to watch the rest of the trailer
properly
i feel like a lot of the environments
are beautiful like
they've nailed a lot of the environments
but something about those two actors
just doesn't look like
it belongs in a lot of the rings and i
don't really know why like elijah wood
is a pretty boy
and we're okay with that
but like seeing those two actors who are
just conversing and i don't feel like
this uh woman is all that different
they maybe just look a little bit like
too clean i don't know there's something
maybe it's the way it's shot i'm really
not sure
like i don't buy that kid is in one of
the rings
i don't know
if the evil rising is left unchecked
it will take us off
find the light
and the shadow will not find you
i think it's the way it's shot
together we can survive this
each of us
must decide who we shall be
a lot of this stuff looks cinematic
there can be no trust between hammer and
rock
eventually one or the other
must surely break
you have been told many lies of middle
earth
so there were some things about this
that i really liked
hopefully the cg is better than the
original movies we can't pretend that
they didn't have a ton of issues okay
you could clearly tell that the hobbits
were just a completely different act
sometimes
there are things in this that i like
like this is absolutely beautiful
there is some really interesting use of
elements in a lot of these shots like
that's a gorgeous shot
um
but i don't know what the conflict is
and i'm not really feeling drawn to any
of the characters other than like
it seems like galadriel is supposed to
be
the main character and a warrior and i
will say not a fan of that
um as much as i
said earlier done my best just distance
myself from
expecting things to be the same
i've enjoyed reading things for far too
long it just never happens i'm like i
just don't get mad about it like i feel
like a lot of the internet does i'm like
it's okay
things can change i still love my
version but i am having a little bit of
trouble with galadriel specifically
being like this warrior who you see with
the sword and this armor all the time
just because it feels a bit forced
um i just don't know why that was
necessary you could have just made a
different character you could have
created a new character
um yeah
that it just feels forced it doesn't
really feel organic to me but maybe it's
just that i'm not you know i'm not used
to that representation so it is being
forced upon me or people like me
specifically who have to be taught
actually she is this like that literally
could be the case
um but there are things about this that
i like
there are some things that i think look
very epic
but then like that i don't know i don't
know why
they don't look like they belong in lord
of the rings is it the costumes this
show clearly is very expensive you can
tell by this trailer
it's
clearly a lot of money has gone into a
lot of this production um
like this looks epic
i like the look of this guy
i don't know dude it's it's strange
it's just something off about it um
i'll be surprised if the
comments here
huh the comments here actually seem to
be okay
okay there i think they're all just
they're all just lying i was i was only
partly reading them until i realized
this and then this
and then this in a row these are all
memes
and i was just like half reading all of
them was like vaguely positive because i
wasn't actually reading them
well it's a little bit annoying because
it means you can't actually get any uh
anybody's impressions but
i i stay in the same i'm not at all
excited about it which is a shame i want
it to be good i would like it to be good
something just looks weird but i'm also
not as angry as everybody else um
like if i don't like it i'll just stop
watching it like i did with halo i'll
just stop uh next is a house of the
dragon sorry i thought it was house of
dragons
which is the game of thrones follow-up
or prequel i don't remember i've not
read game of thrones i only saw the show
and
really enjoyed it until i didn't anymore
the dream
it was clearer than a memory thought the
last two three seasons were not great i
heard the sound of thundering hooves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
and all the dragons roared as one
i consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
the iron throne is the most dangerous
seat in the realm so
when you watch this
compared to that lord of the rings
trailer
this is obviously game of thrones
and it's shot differently and i think it
actually highlights maybe the issue
that i'm not actually excited about this
show at all either to be fair uh because
of how i felt about the end of game of
thrones
um
i think the lighting is maybe the
problem with the faces on lord of the
rings because this has a lot of dramatic
lighting whereas i feel like
in the lord of the rings trailer people
are just fully lit
there are no shadows on their faces
they're not using
lighting for any dramatic effect like
that
becomes a beautiful shot that doesn't
look fake or out of universe because of
the harsh lighting and maybe that's what
it is that's similar to the shots
too easily ended
who else would have a claim
the firstborn child renera
no queen has ever sat the iron front
the king has an heir damon targaryen
i will not be made to choose between my
brother i know matt smith was in it that
was my friend right
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your first duty is to pick a new wife
this is very well sure i have decided to
name a new heir i'm your hair
whoa it's definitely
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bent the knee
a woman would not inherit the iron
throne
because that is the order of things
when i'm queen i will create a new order
[Applause]
[Music]
i like this trailer your family has
dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
targaryens are closer to gods than to
men
worried about her performance she's not
come across as a great actress
she can cut off any challenge to her
succession
i am to inherit the iron throne
she will block my way
our hearts remain as one
our hearts will never won
it's probably longer than it needs to be
oh it is extended trailer
where is juicy
yeah the way they appear on faces is
much cooler it is a little like while i
get that it has to be about dragons
because targaryens
focusing on the dragons that much is not
that that great because we've already
seen them
um but i like the hook of this trailer i
i think
the amount of plot that it's giving me
is like oh okay i understand who is a
potential protagonist who's a potential
antagonist which i can't say for a lot
of the ranks
other than thinking it's probably
galadriel which i'm not a fan of um
i hope this show is actually good and
redeems the game of thrones franchise a
bit season eight feels like they killed
any hype for the franchise but this show
looks really cool i think that's where i
stand too actually i think this looks
good
um season eight and again i think i
didn't like the other two before that so
much
i thought the first few seasons were
like perfection
um i know the show will be great because
the ones working on actually give a [ __ ]
about the story i just hope it's well
received potentially leads to blackfyre
series down the road how perfect is the
trailer you've got your fighting action
your political scheming your dragons
you're intrigued i'm in agreement i
think this is a good trailer
hopefully it's a good show i i like
it's when does it come out
i don't know if it's august 21st so it
been a lot of rings being really close
to each other is gonna make one of these
shows look like trash
and yeah again
they just don't
yeah i just feel like there could be
more dramatic lighting i think maybe
what it is is that looks like a studio
light like the light that's hitting him
and him
it looks like studio lighting and i
think that's what's putting me off maybe
i don't know i don't know dude um the
next one
maybe i'll go with john wick just to
give us a break before we get into
dungeons and dragons this is only a
minute and this is uh the john wick
chapter 4 official teaser trailer
i will watch these movies forever have
you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
i love the law of these movies so much
more than i expected
john wick no one the choreography is
obviously key not even you
great cinematography love the
environments but the law
can kill everyone
[Music]
you ready john
clearly just a teaser
but a great teaser
that's super fun looking forward to it
those are my thoughts
this is exactly how i feel this movie
doesn't need a trailer just to name and
release it and everyone will go can't
wait to see it yeah i agree he's 57 no
way i actually thought he was over
the point of john wick other action
movies struggle to keep up with the
choreography the style the atmosphere
everything feels unique and straight in
your face that's the reason the series
is still alive
from a story perspective these films are
always shallow but nobody expects this i
agree with that they are very stylish um
and that goes a long way
very cool okay so the last one is
dungeons and dragons honor among thieves
official trailer this one was from the
21st so
let's do it
i have virtually no expectations
that looks bad
that also looked bad
here's the thing
we're a team of thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
some rough effects here
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off it's very
guardians
figure it out over a drink probably best
you need i do love this give us a
fighting chance we're gonna need
strength you got this right i know you
don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
they have the whole dnd universe
supporting so much cool stuff
i'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
i think this movie
is going to be and i feel like this is a
great exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
this trailer has set my expectations
very well i i didn't have the thought
this is clearly going to be action
comedy
it's clearly going to be a lot of fun
pretty unhinged crazy stunts crazy stuff
going on
it's probably again probably probably
pretty similar to guardians of the
galaxy but fantasy but it's going to be
silly and fun
um very different tonally
to these other two
uh rather serious
ye old timey uh
film slash tv shows that we're getting
so
yeah this looks fun i reckon this
movie's probably going to be a pretty
good time um nothing overly serious or
overly emotional which i guess i could
say that based on guardians trailers but
the guardians of galaxy movies is like
so emotional to me because of the family
content
they get me
this looks like it'll be fun good d and
d energy i agree with that
dean is trying his hardest to tell a
serious story that blaze are having none
of it
this might not suck i think the
lighthearted and humorous approach is
definitely the way to go
definitely agree with this comment
it's the tone i was hoping the movie
would go for i wouldn't say that i don't
think i was hoping it would go for that
but
it clearly is
and i think michelle rodriguez is a
really good choice so
i think it'll be a fun time um yeah
that's all the trailers that i wanted to
catch up on let me know if i missed any
let me know what you guys think anything
that stood out to you and i guess i will
uh
probably check out both house of the
dragon and rings of power and make some
content about those as well when they
come out
hey
i want everything to be good
why would you want things to be bad ever
just seems unlikely